hey what's up guys my name is Samuel Lee
I am a property investor I make a lot of
money in property and I love to help
other people also succeed in property
investment so here's what's going to be
happening on this week's Q&A Sunday
video I'm going to be answering your
questions from the previous week's Q&A
Sunday and there's some really cool
questions so I'm gonna be doing my best
to give the best answers as possible
which are going to help get you to the
next level in property however while I'm
answering these questions if you're
watching this and you have a question
pop up maybe it's related to what I'm
talking about
maybe it's completely unrelated but
anything to do with property finance
mortgages investments comment your
questions below and here's what I'm
gonna do on next week's video I'm gonna
be answering your questions I'll be able
to as many as I can so don't forget
subscribe turn the notification belt on
so next week your questions will be
answered and you're gonna ping and
you'll be able to watch next week's
video so this week let's have a look see
what we got so we had a guy called the
rocky the rocky - he said I say me well
I have a question for you what happens
if at the end of the lease option
agreement the seller doesn't want to
sell the property anymore
I mean if you sign the lease option
agreement in five years and maybe the
property's gained some value maybe the
seller would resign the agreement and
sell it by himself for more than it was
agreed and let me see something I
appreciate a lot for what you're doing
for the community okay great question
the rocky - so to answer your question
for anyone who doesn't know by the way a
lease option agreement is when you buy a
property now but you pay for it later so
you fix a sale price today and then
maybe you say in five years you have the
option not the obligation to purchase
the price promotes the property at that
step price now Rocky's question is what
happens though at the end of the say
five-year term if the seller says
actually you know what I don't want to
sell it to you anymore I'm good I want
to I want to I want to sell to somebody
else and I've had this happen to me I've
had situations where I've had literally
said I've agreed to buy properties for
seventy-five thousand pounds and then I
at the end of the seven year lease
option agreement I've been like right
I'm buying it it's now worth 120
thousand
and I'm thinking awesome and then the
owner has got cold feet and I said
actually you know what I don't want to
sell it to you anymore it's gone up in
value or can we renegotiate now the
answer the question is that if the
seller could do that it would defeat the
whole purpose of a lease option
agreement like you may as well just say
I want to buy the property in seven
years let's have a conversation they're
like the purpose of the lease option
agreement is that you fix in you lock in
the price now and you have the option to
exercise that purchase at the end of the
term
so even when I've had sellers that have
tried to go back on their word or
they've said actually I've changed my
mind
they cannot do that they are bound to
sell the property at lease option
agreement will stand up in court however
you need to make sure that when you do
the agreement you need to make sure
right at the beginning that the seller
is represented by a solicitor so you
don't just say oh here's a lease option
agreement template that I've drawn up
you know you want to sign you doesn't do
that what you do is you get it drawn it
by a solicitor and you make sure that
the seller is represented because that
way and I'm talking experienced at the
end of the term whether it's five years
ten years however long it is if the
seller tries to pull out their only
reason for pulling out will be I didn't
know what I was doing you know I was I
was signing under duress or they'll say
oh I I was so stressed out that this
person took advantage of me so if
they're represented by a seller in the
beginning it's a solicitor sorry in the
beginning the solicitors job is to make
sure that they know what they're doing
they're not signed on under duress and
it's a fair agreement on both sides it's
a win-win and then at the end of the
agreement they have to sell it you have
the option but they have the obligation
to sell it to you and I've done many of
these so there's the answer
hope that helps rocky go kick some ass
in lease option agreements let's see
what else we got okay
some sad Jan Lynn boo - all these people
put - at the end of the night okay
Samuel very important question for you
what if tenants stopped pate went it
can't stop paying rent then you just
evict them like like in listen property
investing is a business your your house
is your product your tenant is your
customer if you have a customer that's
not paying then you just you
stop doing business with them if the
case of if it's a tenant living in the
house now you can't say you're a day
late on your rent you need to leave now
because tenants do you have rights which
is a good thing because I'm a tenant
anyway the house that I live in I rent
it and then I have lots and lots and
lots of tenants that are my customers
and if you're a day late and the
landlord could just evict you
you know it's fair that the customer has
certain rights but fortunately they do
not have the right to just live in your
house and not pay you rent
that's not one of the rights I think
that have to be I think it's two months
if they're two months behind on rent
then you can serve notice it's a little
bit of process I think the biggest thing
is prevention is always better than cure
so whilst if you've got a tenant that's
not paying you ain't you can eat kind of
victim
it does take just taking a bit of time
just make sure that when you get to you
referenced and properly get a previous
landlord check make sure that they can
afford to live in the property make sure
that they're working and you know it
doesn't happen too often also make sure
you're buying the property in the kind
of area where you're going to attract
decent tenants I always say you don't
want to be buying in the most luxurious
areas because the return on investment
it's not going to be good you also don't
want to be buying in the absolute pits
where it's really rough you kind of want
you know to be not even in the middle
but probably closer to the to the poor
areas but not in a really poor area so
my properties typically where I get
let's say number one out a one out of
ten is red light district broken glass
everywhere boarded up windows that would
be a one and a tenth would be you know
Mayfair in London I'll be looking at
areas that are around about like a three
maybe a four typically four by two that
investing reference the tenants properly
but if they don't pay the ramp just deal
with it
give them their notice and work it out
so I hope that helps let's see what else
we've got
okay Dave t1 house hang I have a
question I hope you can answer regarding
HMOs I'll do my best my friend another
landlord has advised me that I should
issue a joint and several tenancy
agreement to the five tenants in my soon
to be occupied HMO
the tenants do not know each other but
my friend says this doesn't matter and
it seems to offer several advantages are
you familiar with
as I've never heard mention of them
before Thanks
okay Dave um I don't know what the
advantages that your friend is
suggesting that there would be I think
what you're talking about here is when
you have a HMO and you put all the
talents on one ASD contract it's a
logistical once a nightmare but it does
it does come with complications because
you have one asd contract and every time
someone moves it moves out you've got to
put them on take them off of the one asd
contract possible the only reason that
I've ever known people do this is
because the mortgage company will not
let you rent the property out on a
room-by-room basis and have multiple
contracts of tenants so it's kind of
like a loophole where people say okay
well what I'll do is I'll just have one
asd contract and I'll put people on take
people off as they leave so I think
that's the only reason I've ever come
across people that have done that apart
from that reason I don't think there's
any advantages I think it's just
creating extra work I would just I would
rather for my properties I just have a
contract per tenant contract per tenant
if it's a HMO so unless there's any
other crazy advantages that I'm not
aware of which probably not the case I
would just I would just do it the
traditional way hope that helps
okay Kelly Heil three great video Sammie
or thank you your awesome question for
you go for it how can you find out who
the owners of a property are to deal
with them directly rather than asking
through the estate agents renting the
property okay if you have the address
and you want to find out who owns that
property you can do that on land or
registry and it costs three pounds so
that's the answer
have the helps don't forget by the way
if you enjoying this video if you find
these videos useful please do smash the
like button as well just to show that
you enjoying the video and of course if
you're not subscribed subscribe to the
channel if you've got questions if
you're getting offshoots of questions
from me answering these questions then
comment your questions below and don't
forget next week I want to be answering
more I could be answering your questions
as well so do that now that'd be great
okay meda and x4 hi Samuel commentary is
bringing three bedroom house to be
licensed HMO from April 2020 do you
reckon if you invest before that you
need it
okay I don't know that actually that's
news to magnet no comment we're going to
be bringing in I think what you're
probably talking about and I'll do some
research on this but I think you're
probably talking about selective
licensing I don't know if you're talking
about optical 4 or licensing I'm gonna
have to just google this real quick and
find out because I need to and I'm gonna
pause the video I'm gonna google it okay
I'm just googled it and I think I think
what you're talking about is the
mandatory licensing that's coming into
commentary I wasn't aware of that it
does come in certain areas like it's in
Liverpool selective licensing basically
so check with the council ring them up I
don't want to be held account for this
question but my understanding from
seeing similar things in other areas is
that you will need a license even if you
did before April 2020 if they change the
licensing rules my understanding is that
you will need a license now if it's
article 4 and planning that's a whole
separate thing when article 4 comes into
commentary if you've already if you're
already running the profit so you're not
going to be affected by that you're not
gonna need planning permission but
licensing my understanding is you're
gonna need a license even if it's three
beds however please please please please
please PLEASE cool Coventry council tell
them your exact situation because every
council operates with slightly different
rules so I don't want to be giving you
like wrong advice but that would be my
understanding so sorry I couldn't be
more helpful pick up that phone speak to
Coventry Council tell em your situation
and see what they can say my best advice
hope that helps a little bit okay Luke
Jackson says do you always keep your
lease holds up to date or just use the
properties for rental purposes and do
not think about the resale so much no I
do think about the resale so we've we've
leasehold you know you if you're buying
a property like an apartment and there's
and there's a leasehold on it
you want that lease all to at least
outlive you like at least so I have got
some my apartment store when they sold
but they're over 100 years over a
hundred years and you're pretty okay but
if you've got a short lease on it yeah
you're right it just means that you're
gonna be really you're really gonna
struggle so if you ever need to sell
that property it brings the value
drastically down
so for me I always prefer freehold
because then you earn the property you
also earn the land
I do think about resale even though my
plan when I buy a property is not to
sell it you need an exit strategy so if
the property's concrete construction or
something like that it's not standard
any thinking well this isn't going to
sell very easily at the end that means
you've got no exit strategy which is
never a safe place to be in as a
property investor so I would personally
try and stick to freehold if you do go
for lease old make sure there's a really
long lease on it absolutely for sure
hope that helps okay last question
mister ej4
says when's the next fitness update
quite enjoyed that video I'm glad that
you quite enjoyed that video that's
awesome the next fitness update I'm not
sure we did one real soon anyone that
doesn't know I have hired a full-time
personal trainer in fact on the entry
into this video or leave a I'll leave a
video so you can watch kind of what's
happening he's working me hard he's
working me every single day he's helping
you with the meal with my meals and just
traveling with me and it's going pretty
good I've lost like almost a stone over
the last month which is great but for me
I'm just gonna just quietly get on with
it I have got a group of our Facebook
group called Fitness freedom challenge
so you can find that on Facebook Fitness
freedom challenge with Samuel Leeds and
okay as you asked I'll do a vlog very
soon in the next couple of weeks I'll
doing I'll do a vlog for you that's all
for today folks hope you enjoyed that
Q&A someday please don't forget to
comment your questions below I mean
honestly if you if you what's the one
thing you need to know in properties to
take to the next level because if you're
watching this and you're not financially
free then clearly is because you lack
knowledge somewhere and if you not like
knowledge somewhere that means that the
needs to be something that you need to
know I want to know what that is and I
want you to comment that below and then
I'll do my best to answer that next week
also if you've not been down to the
property investors crash course it's a
two-day course it was created by me and
honestly it's a game changer in property
so if you want to be financially free in
property of highly suggested you have
them already or even if you have already
get down to the property investors crash
course is free on the house so you can
get booked on to the property investors
crash course all right here
if you want to watch the fitness freedom
challenge video you can watch that right
here and also please don't forget to
subscribe if you don't subscribe then
I'm gonna hunt you down I'll find you
I'm just kidding right over here
subscribe thanks so much guys I'll see
you next time